imagine the best schoolteachers making
millions of dollars a year making more
than star baseball players that's
already happening in one country it's
something I learned from the PBS series
school incorporated here's part two of
the stossel shortened version of a
documentary made by Andrew Colson
wouldn't it be great if the best
teachers earned that same remuneration
and that same recognition well here in
Korea they do John well mr. choi is a
national star a lot of students have
fallen in love with his lectures in the
past students from outside Seoul had to
come take these classes during vacation
but as Internet technology improved kids
got the opportunity to listen to great
lectures in the comfort of their own
homes there aren't really many celebrity
teachers so we have to pay online
courses he was like a celebrity to them
and he actually helped me with the
subject that I did not really develop he
helps a lot of people on average over
hundred thousand students taking my
lessons that's how he makes millions and
since these most popular teachers make
the most money
teacher compete within the market become
like entertaining and educated at the
same time now teachers competing to be
entertaining and educational that
happens in the private education market
government schools their different
public high schools to salaries
seniority based in government schools
the best teachers don't make more money
mr. choi is thankful for private
schooling to be able to share the things
that you know and get paid for doing
that is actually a miracle America's
private school sector is not yet that
robust but there are now some charter
schools that do make a big difference
one of Oakland's worst schools was
gradually turned in to the
highest-scoring School in California
every racial ethnic and socio-economic
subgroup of students at these schools
easily outperforms it statewide peers
and all of them beat the average for
wealthier white students
the high school has topped the
Washington Post's list of the nation's
best Jamila transferred here in seventh
grade this charter school was very
different from her government-run school
it was just a really big transition
because the school that I went to they
actually gave me a textbook and put us
in the back of the classroom to learn
and teach ourselves but the enemies of
choice keep trying to kill off their
competition
they fight charter schools vouchers
school tax credits education savings
account they say charter schools are
unaccountable because they're not run by
the state but real accountability really
comes from government regulators
regulators may sleep on the job or take
bribes or just follow meaningless rules
real accountability happens when parents
get to choose which school gets their
money if there were no regulations at
all wouldn't some private schools try to
take advantage of families and wouldn't
the most likely victims be children
whose parents had little schooling
themselves
here in India a lot of schools are
taking advantage of poor families back
in 1999 a team of researchers made
surprise visits to schools around the
country in village after village they
found one type of school that
consistently have the worst facilities
and the least learning most deadly
groups and barely any had drinking water
and if you're wondering why anyone would
pay for that kind of service it turns
out there's a good reason they have to
the findings I just described are for
public schools that is what happens in
the government schools the beaches then
isn't anyone who's going to be held
accountable
this teacher talked with a public school
teacher I think that also what's been
going on with you and she said all
managed to get a government job my life
is said and I said was said in what ways
she said what I'm never going to be
fired this is a job for life and it pays
me well and I don't even have to go she
hasn't been to school for last
year-and-a-half since she was posted
back coulson then interviews british
education professor James Tooley truly
traveled the world to research how the
poorest people educate kids he went to
the slums of India and I found something
which which changed my life I found a
private school a low-cost private school
in those days charging the equivalent of
about one US dollar per month found one
and then a second and a third and soon I
found this Federation of low-cost
private schools when he told his fellow
educators about that they dismiss this
discovery what you found is a couple of
businessmen ripping off the poor and
anyway it's only happening in Hyderabad
in India we know about it's a small
thing you know I thought ripping off the
poor but that's not what I've seen there
I've seen dedicated entrepreneurs who
are running schools they come in on
their their weekends and run science
fair you think okay this must be charity
maybe the mosques are supporting them
some NGO some non non-government
organization is supporting them when you
see in five 10 15 and you hear of 500
these schools you realize that can't be
the kids
there has to be a financially
sustainable business model I talked a
lot of parents said yeah you're poor you
know and why are you spending money on
the private schools when the government
schools are free I'll never forget one
said in the in the government schools
our children are abound and sure enough
I went to see one of these government
schools 130 children sitting on the
floor the government school just around
the corner from here 130 children all
bright-eyed eager to learn eager to
welcome the stranger in their midst
doing that abandoned there are
government school regulators duly
interviewed them and they admitted that
they take bribes
they were quite upfront about it they
came they sat in the office they sat in
a comfortable desk they took the money
they didn't even bother to look in the
school they had a nice cup of hot chai
and if they went dozens of scientific
studies have now looked at these budget
private schools in India and elsewhere
and what most of them find is that
private schools are outperforming
government schools to spend three or
four times as much per pupil these
parents care about that schooling they
said why are there only 10 computers why
was a teacher absent last week they care
they're paying money and because they're
paying they will keep the schools
accountable that's a very important
thing which you mess with at your peril
that's just a sample of Andrew Coulson's
three-part PBS series School Inc can
watch the whole thing on the free to
choose networks YouTube page
unfortunately Coulson did not live to
see his documentary finished he died
while completing it school Inc is a
wonderful memorial to him and his fine
work
you